anyway they're really loud noise like an
m16 is 160 decibels and something that
loud just a second or two of or a
split-second worth of exposure can cause
some hearing damage whereas if you're
talking about like a noisy Street a loud
restaurant 85 decibels you could hear
you could be exposed for eight hours
before you start to run a risk so it's
it's a combination of how loud it is and
how long you're exposed so it's a huge
problem in the military it's the number
one expense that the VA deals with it's
a billion dollars a year for hearing
loss and tinnitus for hearing
disabilities and you think well duh put
in earplugs or ear cuffs and that's
great until you really you need to
communicate you need to hear somebody
yelling get down or there's someone over
there in these you know these are pretty
important things to hear and so the the
idea is that you want to be able to
protect hearing but also preserves what
they call situational awareness like you
what's what's going on around you
because about fifty percent of that
comes from hearing even somebody riding
a bike down a street you know that's a
lot of it is you're aware of things by
sound even if you're not you don't
realize that so the military's challenge
has been to create a to come up with a
way to protect hearing but also enable
you to hear more quiet noises so there's
something in the special operations they
have something that they're using which
is really cool it's these ear cuffs that
magically not magically it's technology
but they they attenuate loud noise they
minimize loud noises they sense
something that's over a certain decibel
level cut that but amplify quiet noises
like a human voice so you put these on
and when they're when they're switched
on its kind of amazing it's like you can
you're kind of like the Bionic Woman
you're able to hear a conversation
across the street so so that's the
challenge of military hearing how do you
the other thing the other thing that's
that's tough is that when really not
know starts happening there's no warning
so you could be going along for hours in
a
convoy and there's no there's not any
firefight or anything going on but
suddenly an IE D goes off with so you
you don't you don't have any warning to
put in put on or in your ear protection
so that's the other challenge and it's
hard to convince a soldier to wear a
heavy headset the entire eight hours
that they're driving somewhere so you
know somebody put it as the military
doesn't have a noise problem they have a
quiet problem because a lot of time it's
it's not loud but suddenly it's loud and
you don't have the time and now your
hearings blown like so many military
technologies it's something that may
start out with a specific military
application but it finds its way to the
civilian world and I actually want a
pair just to put on in the subway and
eavesdrop to the other in the car it
really is when I was when I was young
there was a show The Bionic Woman and
I'm dating how ancient I am but one of
the things she was doing in some tragic
accident she was rebuilt and they gave
her bionic hearing and she you'd see her
kind of got like ddddd but then she
would be able to hear conversation like
the bad guy across the street having a
conversation and this is what these
things do it's pretty spectacular